[Musique]
bienvenue à 24,60 hors série nicole
gladu est une femme courageuse elle est
atteinte d'une maladie dégénérative
irréversible qui lui cause une très
grande souffrance assez battu aux côtés
de jean truchon qui souffre lui aussi
d'une maladie incurable elle s'est
battue donc pour obtenir le droit de
mourir dans la dignité pour le droit
d'avoir accès à cette aide médicale à
mourir
elle s'est donc battu pour que cet accès
soit élargie qu'on change les critères
mais la bataille devant les tribunaux
elle l'a gagné et l'ont gagnée ils ont
fait l'histoire judiciaire du canada en
voici une qui tue le jeu qui est sûre si
elle apporte une lumière au bout du
tunnel
il faut aussi mieux courage l'ancienne
dénomination que la volonté de réduire
tous genres le jugement sur l'aide
médicale à mourir va ouvrir les portes
du paradis à tous ceux et celles qui
souffrent comme moi de manière physique
et psychologique
un soulagement je vais digérer je vais
réfléchir je vais mourir et je sais pas
exactement qu'un mais je vais
certainement me prévaloir de la liberté
qu'on vient de me redonner
[Musique]
du colza du bien évidemment qu'à 60
merci merci de prendre le temps le temps
doit extrêmement précieux pour vous
depuis ce jugement historique
la juge baudouin au mois de septembre
non aux mesures on ne mesure plus le
teint de la même façon si tu as la foi à
t'aider à la fois l'un parce que bon je
pense parce que j'ai pas je me sens pas
obligé d'avoir arrête il d'un de le
prendre le temps de vivre de savourer
quoi une certaine liberté que vous a
donné la cour oui puis tout le monde
pourvu qu'elles sont c'est qu'un séguin
logique j'ai commencé à égrener dans ma
tête
les occasions bon ça ça va être mon
dernier noël c'est sur mais bon à noël
gdg design extraordinaire il ya des
choses de prévues après soleil en en
janvier après sophie louis en marge et
deux anniversaires qui me tient à coeur
arm et un autre en juin
ce serait le dernier anniversaire va
levier aux modes doux est-ce que vous
avez le goût de vivre
c'était c'est évident vous êtes battus
pour le droit de mourir quand vous vivez
dingman mais vous avez le goût de vivre
là le sens de la vie pour vous étant que
c'était mais moins massive a demandé
pourquoi voulez-vous me veil et le
chaque fois je dis je veux pas mourir
mais je veux arrêter de souffrir et ça
fait tellement d'années que le syndrome
post-polio se faufile dans ma vie mais
taille et à la bande st j'ai souvent dit
que cette maladie dégénérative comme
d'autres c'est comme un escalier qu'on
ne dévoile pas qu'on ne descend pas
marche par marche mais qu on dévale par
paliers et la baie le jura fait son pain
j'ai l'impression d'être au deuxième
sous-sol
vous êtes une femme très engagée dans
votre vie depuis
d'abord même en fameuse été enfin
adoptée vous avez souvent la polio mais
vous êtes une femme très très active
devenu journaliste denis carrière
impressionnante ou si oui belge rjh
internationale j'ai fait beaucoup de
choses comme qu'on prédisait impossible
pour moi une survivante orange et wii
puis vraiment quelqu'un quand j'étais
petit on disait de moi que j'étais à
nantes
c'était vrai et je dis que si le [ __ ]
elle avait existé à l'époque on m'avait
sûrement donné mais j'étais pour moi la
vie le c'était le vert toujours été à
moitié plein alors que pour d'autres et
à moitié vide
ils sont deux pas de mérite c'est un
caractère avec lequel on vient au monde
et pour moi le c'était c'était la
découverte c'était explorer c'était
j'étais la petite fille à 20 la peau new
yok quand ma famille allait passer dix
semaines à la campagne mais j'étais la
petite fille grippe et un escalier
branle un tube était formellement
interdit
pour ali cacher le batte de base-ball
des jeunes frères de berre sas et
s'arrêter quand le virus de la polio
davin les deux vaccins des années 50
alors ce qui ce qui encore aujourd'hui
résiste aux facs et là c'est difficile à
moins de bons mots et de compréhension
alors j'ai été victime de ces trois mois
dans le coma
revenue à elle comme une petite poupée
de chiffon nous avait défié tous les
pronostics nous concerne
oui puis un médecin et je me rappelle de
sa phase que j'ai compris au premier
degré les impressions des années après
le petit tiroir souvenirs sites ouverts
gaby avec un seul poumon de
fonctionnaires nicole n'est pas censé
vivre mais il semble qu'elle avait
décidé autrement et on lui mettra pas de
bagdad
les jambes et c'est un peu ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui avec toutes celles plus tard
parce que il faut quand même reconnaître
avec monsieur touchant tous les deux
vous avez réussi à infléchir deux
parlements oui au gouvernement vont
devoir agir est ce que pour enlever dans
la loi qui balisent l'aide médicale à
mourir
deux critères pour le québec la fin de
vie et à ta voix la mort elle-même à la
mort naturelle est généralement prédisez
vous la connaissez par coeur oui oui
vous l'avez beaucoup vous avez plaidé
beaucoup contre ces deux dispositions
c'est toute cette énergie combative que
vous portiez en vous pour mener ce
combat
un moment donné quand je reçus une
grosse dépression
je m en k-1 atteint je me suis entendu
me dis oh mentalement je m en k-1 on
peut haïr une personne et là j'étais
terrorisée par ce que ça i reçoit même
nom ça mange pas de personnes qui est
mais on peut pas vous fuir l'objet de sa
main cassée soi-même et j'étais très
donc c'est après ça que je tombé en
dépression mais puis j'envisageais
l'époque ce qui m'attendait j'ai
découvert après coup que j'avais pas des
anges et gris et quand je regarde la
personne que je suis devenu physiquement
je pouvais bien je pouvais bien pour moi
vous savez c'était comme une trahison
j'avais eu la polio jeunes était battu
on avait dit que je devais pas vivre des
vies survécu et pour moi le kg lui misé
opérations avec les techniques de
l'époque lé de grève la colonne
vertébrale
tu te rendre à l'école mais là pour moi
c'était la belle a dit j'en ai fini
c'est comme si je faisais de
l'anthropomorphisme j'avais je pense
personnifié dans ma tête c'était
vraiment quelqu'un c'était quelque chose
et quand la polio site s'est imposé dans
ma vie
c'était comme une trahison c'est comme
gagner deux fois le mauvais billets et
messieurs on n'y peut rien moment donné
de la vie c'est la vie mais je dois dire
que ça m'a excité puis facile pour moi
de me battre au long de toute ma vie que
de réaliser que j'étais très bonnes pour
faire reculer les limites
c'est vraiment un plus alors là je suis
rendu au moment de couper le fil et
entre table je me suis beaucoup impliqué
dans mourir dans la dignité qui était
stiggy par la députée véronique hivon
pour laquelle je continue d'avoir une
grande admiration et bobby la loi est
sorti qu'il ne pouvait pas faire
autrement
c'était il fallait qu'ils suivent une
comptine monde de santé selon leur
juridiction provinciale
il était la feuille de vie qui était le
critère après y est arrivé ces 14 ou au
fédéral et je me rappelle encore de la
lutte
c'est vers là dessus ils sont arrêtés
juste avant le veto par respect pour les
autorités élues alors c'était la mare
naturelle raisonnablement prévisibles
je ne sais encore de m'émerveiller de
masse et élastique
on peut l'utiliser il selon les désirs
des uns et des autres à en décembre 2007
j'ai demandé à un médecin de famille qui
est extraordinaire c'est l'accepterai
demeure de m'accorder les mythiques à
l'amour et à me dit pour vous oui
meilleur à mes revenus en janvier 2010
se noyer que leurs bombes au club book à
me disant je la revois encore devant -
je veux pas perdre mon monde droite
pratique elle avait consulté notamment
le collège des médecins qui à l'époque
était intraitable là dessus
alors c'est l'objet par l'air l'ironie
qui vont celles auxquelles beau référé
un maître ménard et c'est là donc au
printemps 2007 que au bureau de m ménard
pour jean truchon et moi même on ne loge
il
la requête et c'était au oui contre le
gouvernement avez vous le sentiment
d'avoir écrit l'histoire sociale du
québec et du canada par ce combat là
parce que la juge baudoin à la fin de
son jugement juste avant de conclure oui
elle dit finalement ce débat de société
n'aurait pu exister sans le courage et
la détermination de deux individus
jean touchons et nicole dadu qui ont
porté cette cause sur leurs épaules et
tous ne restera à jamais marqué par leur
témoignage et tient leur transmet son
profond respect c'est émouvant c'est
quand même oui c'est émouvant
on savait pas mon jeu j'espérais je
pensais qu'on des engrais ne peut jamais
être sûr là dedans
et quand vont à voir comment appeler la
veille de la publication du texte
en dix ans on a gagné il a évidemment je
vais bouffer de d'adrénaline j'étais
très heureuse mais quand j ai lu et pij
c'était un jugement tellement soigner
tellement approfondie que je me disais
pour moi il y aura pas d'appel
et effectivement il y a pas d'appel est
il là j'étais fier ouais j'étais fier je
me suis dit on s'est battus pour nous je
me suis battue comme mon ami steve me
force à me pousse à me battre quand je
lis sur un gros obstacle mais je veux
pas conscience de faire de faire
l'histoire je vous l'avais un peu plus
oui après coup parce que on va devoir
s'arrêter quelques minutes le temps
d'une pause on va reprendre tout c'est
après que je vois qu'on aborde vous avez
du sang comme 100 parlementaires salle à
mourir dans la dignité j'ai rêvé ma vie
avant de vivre mais
ouais c'est une très belle phrase envoyé
revenir merci merci nicolas todt su
rester avec toi la mission poursuit la
conversation avec du code l'adulte se
tapent à la pause
[Musique]
on parle toujours en et au nazisme c'est
d'assister de phase terminale pour moi
c'est un concept dans mon cas qui est
complètement abstraite
moi je meurs à petit feu depuis les
années 90 lorsque pour moi car c'est pas
un évangile que jean paul à quiconque
lorsque pour moi je déciderai que ma vie
n'est plus qu'une existence dénué de
sangles pour moi je couperai le film je
poursuis la conversation avec nicole
delhaye du qui a une grande victoire
devant les tribunaux
cette année ça a marqué l'histoire
juridique du québec et du canada nycole
delà du on vient de vous entendre dire
mourir à petit feu depuis les années 90
vous vouliez avoir ce libre choix ça a
pris tellement d'années pour mener le
combat mais vous l'avez menée avec
l'entente est proposé avec une grande
cohérence ça c'est votre choix personnel
c'est pour vous mais en même temps on
n'impose pas aux autres nangis souvent
répété c'est une lois permissives elle
ce n'est pas une loi coercitive limite
ce qu'est l'amour et c'est une option
c'est audois qui permet aux gens qui
voudraient librement et bien renseigné
et tout ça qui voudrait terminer leur
vie de cette façon de le faire
en quoi c'est une avancée sociale mais
je crois qu'il savait que le suicide a
été décriminalisée au canada 60 doses
mais l'aide au suicide c'est écouter
même que des médecins sicile s'il
voulait et des centres la loi soit
changée il serait passible de 14 ans
d'emprisonnement alors c'est comme si on
disait aux gens mais ouais vous pourrez
vous direz mais celle ci est subtile ue
et moi je m'en réjouis rappelle avoir
que je les écris dans un mémoire
je me rappelle avoir lu sur internet
mais comment est ce qu'on fait pour
qu'il y avait un médecin
pendant que certaines des amis qui avait
10 ans ce pas compliqué tu regardes sur
internet
ben moi je peux conduire ma vie comme
socrate cage fait des choses je sais de
les faire de la meilleure façon de
passer votre consultant des experts
quels médicaments par lequel dosage
après ça me mettre un sac sur la tête
mais tout fait ma famille je suis plutôt
gourmande bâtir et le bal bref avait pas
grand chose je me disais mais tant qu'à
faire si j'y suis obligé j'irai à zurich
parce que c'est là qu on peut se faire
administrer les médicale à mourir mais
elle est là puis encore heureux que j'ai
les moyens de le faire financiers mais
allez là c'est tristounet
moi j'ai écrit plus il vrai là on est
chez - j'ai écrit que je voulais mourir
avec mes mais mes grands amis j'ai des
amis extraordinaire depuis le collège et
comme le dit j'ai gagné le gros lot à la
loterie de l'amitié et je voudrais
mourir chez huawei on admire la vue
extraordinaire que je ris sur le fleuve
et avec une flûte de champagne rosé dans
une meilleure canapé de foie gras
alors ça c'est pas possible de faire ça
est-ce que ce luth à donner un sens
particulier votre vie mais ça finit par
le faire oui je lis pas fait pour ça
mais quand mon instinct
on est un hymne à propulser m'a poussé à
me battre même moment donné c'était pas
si je vois pas comment j'aurais pu
battre seulement pour - votre question
me permet de dire ça et j'étais vraiment
un dhimmi de voir qu'on était on en
était encore là puissent savez on est
une population vieillissante au québec
et au fur et à mesure on connaît tous
directement ou indirectement quelqu'un
dont la mort nous a profondément ébranlé
le genre de mort qu'on veut pas pour soi
ou pour quelqu'un d'autre
alors aujourd'hui mais maintenant il ya
toutes sortes de développement pourquoi
obliger les gens à vivre sur av ait à
souffrir
alors moi je dis ce qu'ils veulent vive
est repris ils le font je respecte ça
mais moi je ne veux pas je me dis j'ai
74 ans je me dis j pl qu'on tarde à
d'autres je n'ai pas de preuves à faire
avec les autres j'ai vu que j'avais pas
vis-à-vis de moi-même j'ai pas de
conjoint d'enfants ou d'employés qui
dépendent de moi alors c'était moins de
finir ma vie comme je veux et en même
temps ces données est-ce qu'on peut
aller jusqu'à parler d'espoir quand on
ne fait ce choix là comme vous l'avez
mes fins j'ai l'espoir c'est un espèce
de sérénité parce que on se dit bon je
vais être capable de faire ce que je
veux faire ça réduira personnes le même
mes amis me disent on en 2006 neuf avec
toi par une telle scène ou fait la paix
puis je dois vous dire que ted bape
ça fait plaisir de savoir que des gens
aux intérêts de notre départ mais non
c'est vraiment c'est finir finir ma vie
d'une façon digne que direz vous
aux personnes qui sont pas d'accord avec
vous qui en ont peur de cette liberté là
et que c'est pour les personnes
vulnérables grand danger qu'est ce que
vous leur dites en fait le concept de
vulnérabilité soit vraiment le site est
évoquée à toutes les eaux
il ya toujours des risques dans tout
mais si on s'occupait toujours dit qu'on
ferait rien dans la vie on se parle sur
la lune certain et je pense qu'il faut
parce que vous savez ça fait longtemps
si vous parlais des médecins c'est
angers ça fait longtemps qu'ils se
pratique de l'aide médicale amoureux à
mourir dans les hôpitaux mais non pas
selon la volonté du patient
mais selon la volonté toute puissante
jusqu'à récemment des bêtises on peut
par exemple vous injecter un produit de
l'expression même de cercles on peut
vous administrer un produit qui vaut
qu'à des vaudous l'art mais comme on
disait
si l'objectif du geste médical des paul
amar type doux alors mieux encore je
trouve ce pays pour le malade parce que
chacun a sa marque et je me dis la seule
chose dont on n'est pas responsable
c'est notre naissance mais pour le reste
y compris la vie je trouve qu'on devrait
respecter les individus dental leur
choix que mamad année j'ai écrit
quelqu'un m'avait dit tu devrais pas
écrire sur l'hécatombe sur je me dis que
je devrais ligré j'avais dit à supposer
que vivent à tout prix soit souhaité
herbe on en a plus les moyens
et ils sont écoutés 7 ans 4 e mon
premier mémoire de jugement puis j'avais
dit alors que le budget de la santé
accapare déjà 45 % de notre budget suivi
pas très loin pour l'éducation alors les
27 autres ministères grappiller les
restes quand j'avais dix ce serait bien
plus utilement employés pour par exemple
procurer des médicaments très coûteux a
déjà qu'ils peuvent en profiter qu'ils
le veulent et sociales choquer les gens
mais encore une fois il ya déjà acquis
qui conforte l'objectif est la
conséquence si c'était l'objectif
d'économiser n'en seraient pas d'accord
je pense pour que ce soit le cas non
plus mais c'est la conséquence je les
accepte volontiers que quelqu'un qui
meurt à 74 au lieu de mourir comme il
n'est par 85 ans parce qu'on a d'autres
succès extraordinaire voici ce que les
lecteurs du tricot nouvelliste mais
qu'on fasse pas de la démagogie en
disant que c'est ce qu'ont convenu le
savez une chose qui m'a étonné c'est que
les réactions que j'ai eu à une
exception près le dans la presse plus
mais dans mon entourage et sid les
parfaits inconnus tout le monde ont été
favorables
les gens me reconnaissent que j'ai pas
mal médiatisé preuve disent merci bravo
félicitations
quelqu'un me dit va stationner merci
pour ceux qui nous suivent sans jeu
matin de bordeaux i sabords combler sa
mort sa mort avait conforté je vous sens
sereine vous savourez la vie vous êtes
heureuse mais vous souffrez offensé seul
le bruit le dilemme comment se
prépare-t-on axe fort mal comment vous
préparez-vous à ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est peut-être un peu
tous les anniversaires tête au mois de
juin avant votre prochain adversaire
comment on se prépare comme on vit
chaque minute comment on aborde la vie
meilleure pour la maman je peux vous
dire j'ai eu beaucoup de publicité
autour de ça et là je me dis mais noël
ça va être mon dernier noël et noël vont
être un peu à plat vie comme pour tout
le monde a passé les fêtes là il va
falloir vous allez vous pouvez rire de
moins de couper si vous voulez va
falloir que je fasse un grand ménage
parce que j'aime femme dormait
j'accumule j'accumule les paperasses et
je suis pas capable de jeter quelque
chose que je n'ai pas terrier donc je
vais faire ce we puis pour le reste j'ai
pas de je veux profiter de ce qu il plus
important de ce qui passe est-ce qu'on
est porté à façon bilan de vie on a le
temps de le faire c'est important de le
faire mais je pense que lille s'est fait
un peu tout seul
ironiquement c'est peut-être à la faveur
et des autres budgets accordés les
cliques questions des jeunes poussent à
revenir en arrière mais je dois dire que
je suis plutôt contente je m'étais juré
petit dej' abedi j'aurais attendu ma
mère adoptive disait ça et puis c'était
pour elle le verre est toujours à moitié
vide soucier ça peut davis ouvert
tristounet alors elle regrettait le
passé et elle criait l'avenir qu'elle
gaspille elle parisiens souvent et moi
je m'étais dit je veux pas faire ça et
je pense que si je n'ai pas d'amertume
c'est parce que j'ai profité de toutes
les occasions qui se présentaient à
moins il ça me laisse de très bons
souvenirs quand vous avez témoignée à la
commission parlementaire sur mon rêve à
la dignité vous avez dit j'ai rêvé ma
vie avant de vivre mes rêves qu est ce
que vous vous
de quand j'étais enfant avant que
j'aille à l'école pour la première fois
l'école secondaire puis je passais mes
journées à lire et tout ça je rêvais
j'imaginais jamais une forte imagination
est bon par exemple j'avais le rêve de
devenir journaliste
je lis réalisé avec juliette écrits du
jugement du collège joly fait je voulais
devenir correspondante parlementaire je
lui fais et puis j'étais très
intéressent à l'étranger mais je me suis
retrouvé à new york
alors finalement donc brl pathos peux
complètement me se sont pas mal réalisés
alors oui j'ai rêvé ma vie avant de
vivre mes rêves qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on retienne de vous mon dieu
deux mois
c'est peut-être le movie qui cristallise
tous qu'on dise que je n'ai j'ai eu à
coeur de ne rien gaspiller de ma vie ça
c'est vraiment je trouve que c'est tout
mais on est toujours
qui suis-je pas dire qu'on retienne le
le le verbe vie ouvrière et j'ai vécu
avec passion et je voudrais je voudrais
pas envie que outre-rhin
merci beaucoup de nous ouvrir vers c'est
noté mesdames messieurs merci d'avoir
été avec nous à la prochaine
[Musique]